hallo mein name ist luca dieser patrick
witz wird langsam echt langer okay wir
fangen mit dem video ich befinde mich
gerade in minecraft ich weiß dass heute
nicht freitag ist und freitag auf meinem
kanal der minecraft tag ist aber das
heißt ja nur dass freitags wirklich
immer minecraft kommt und es kann auch
öfter die woche kommen also es kann auch
die ganze woche weiter kommt es kann
aber auch die ganze woche kann freitag
kommt da sind wir wieder bei dem punkt
angelangt wo ich mir sagen dass ich
kommen projekte bescheuert ist kann noch
mal die ganze woche lang minecraft
kommen es kann aber auch mal eine woche
seien wohl nur freitags minecraft ist
und heute haben wir zwei mal die woche
heute haben wir zwei mal die woche luca
de einfach so jetzt bin ich wieder da
und wir ja ich spiele halt minecraft ich
befinde mich gerade in der survival
games lobby und wir gehen einfach mal
komm baby boom hört sich doch ganz gut
an da sind jetzt auch schon direkt in
der runde drin und ich sehe direkt auch
da unten die kiste die endlos habe ich
überhaupt habe ich dann hört man was ich
hoffe man hört irgendwie toren ich habe
sogar schon ein schwert und jetzt hab
ich ja sogar noch ein schwert und bohren
und jetzt werde ich dir direkt um da
oben ist ja sogar flug ab so gut wie
gewonnen
well sech och nö
das ist doch nicht man zu fett sagt wir
sind in einer neuen runde denn vorhin
war einfach nur hacker am start
ich habe hier schon wieder ein schwert
und dann habe ich a
warum warum schickst du mich direkt du
bist direkt tot da gehe ich auch
direkter sagt jetzt auch nicht nee das
ist ja auch dann haste minecraft an der
runde folien und hacker waren habe ich
mir gedacht ich geh jetzt eine runde
hoffentlich keine hacker drin sind und
ich nehme direkt die kiste hier oben
habe direkten schwert schuhe habe ich
auch direkt an rosa habe ich du kriegst
mich nicht
alle sex
ich glaub die vier maps hier vorne waren
einfach nicht so ganz meine maps ich das
liegt an den web stars vorhin wirklich
nur eine website habe ich mir gedacht
ich suche jetzt die sonne als coolen
mehr braucht man wirklich noch hier in
der mitte die kisten drin hat das war ja
schon immer meine spezialität da
hinzulaufen und ein spender hier vorne
ist auch noch eine kiste wo wir auch
schon direkt unsere rose drin finden
dass man aber alles gar keinen sinn wir
brauchen einfach nur schwer hat pvp
tipps mit luca schleicht euch von hinten
an
ihr müsst übrigens ein schwert haben und
ich habe beschwert also ich habe
einstein stattgefunden hinten
anschleichen das war super augen wvp
trägt alle kisten mitnehmen denn dann
hat man auch erst mal das essen und
dabei aber natürlich auch immer den
überblick bei windigen gegner kommen
kann wenn ihr dann verfolgt werdet könnt
ihr auch einfach dann ein
ablenkungsmanöver machen einfach auf ihn
drauf geht um ihm zu zeigen
er hatte noch ein herz ist ein hacker
comex machen die sogar team ja wo seid
ihr super nein teams sind nicht erlaubt
auch wenn es da ja ich bisher immer nur
probleme mit den kisten hatte habe ich
mir diesmal mehr brauchst du die kiste
direkt unter einem ist ich hier
dementsprechend direkt mal eben schnell
ein schwert habe und erst noch zeit das
weiß natürlich den profi luca ihr direkt
natürlich abel ein witz da sehr drauf
gegangen bin wollte desktop das merkt
mit der genau da die schutzzeit nun
beendet ist werde ich jetzt einfach auch
mal direkt ins gefecht ziehen
nachdem ich mir die kiste da ganz oben
geholt haben
ich hab sogar eine weder tunika die
wollte ich mir schon die ganze zeit
bestellen hier in existierende steinachs
hammer jetzt müssen wir halt nur noch
ein paar gegner finden die sache ist es
wenn ich zum als pvp profi hat in seiner
runde bin ist halt das wirklich
tatsächlich sehr viele einfach angst
haben
der da oben versteckt sich
beispielsweise auch einfach gerade von
mir aber dafür hat man ja eine angel und
kann einfach ganz simpel oder ihn
einfach töten das was sich nämlich jetzt
hubert schön hinter verstecken der denkt
nämlich ich sehe ihn nicht und dann das
hat vielleicht tatsächlich eine bessere
rüstung natürlich aber schnell auf dem
trotz gibt dem kombi sluka computing
mama
ich hasse meine frau h